nos dicen que la figura a es una imagen
a escala de la figura p
esta es la figura y esta es la figura ve
la escala que mapea la figura y a la
figura b es uno a dos y medio cuál es el
valor de x pausa en el vídeo y vean si
pueden resolverlo vamos a ver x es la
longitud de este lado en la figura a y
su lado correspondiente en la figura b
tiene una longitud de 5 una forma de
pensarlo es que la razón entre x y 5
debe de ser de 1 a 2 y medio porque esa
es la escala para pasar de la figura a a
la figura p entonces la razón voy a
escribirlo la razón de x a 5 debe de ser
una razón equivalente a la razón que hay
de 1 a 2 y medio
ok pero vamos a pensar en esto para
pasar de dos y medio a cinco tenemos que
multiplicar por dos por lo tanto para
pasar de 1 a x también multiplicamos por
2 así que el valor de x es igual a 2 si
es una copia a escala al multiplicar
esto por dos y medio obtenemos 5
entonces el factor de escala es uno a
dos y medio hagamos otro ejemplo aquí
nos dicen que la figura a es una imagen
a escala de la figura ve aquí tenemos
las dos figuras y nuevamente queremos
saber el valor de x observen que aquí no
nos dan el factor de escala pero
nosotros podemos conocerlo como bueno
aquí podemos ver que cuando pasamos de
este lado que corresponde a este lado
que forma un ángulo recto con la base y
esto
es el lado más largo que también forma
un ángulo recto con la base así que
vamos a establecer algunas razones por
ejemplo podemos decir que la razón de 3
a 4 es igual a la razón que hay de x a
7.2 vamos a escribirlo x a 7.2 entonces
cómo podemos saber el valor de x como
pasamos de cuatro a 7.2 porque lo
multiplicamos tal vez quieran usar una
calculadora o tal vez lo hagan
mentalmente 2 x 36 y 72 y 36 es 2 por 18
entonces y 4 por 18 el 72 4 por 1.8 es
7.2 pero si no se sienten muy cómodos
con los cálculos mentales simplemente
podemos hacer la división 4 entra en 7
una vez y 4 por 1 es 4 lo restamos y nos
queda 3 ponemos el decimal que tenemos
el 2 y el 4 entra 8 veces en el número
32 o dicho de otra manera 8 por 4 es 32
y hemos terminado entonces para pasar de
4 a 7.2 necesitamos multiplicar por 1.8
así que al pasar de 3 a equis también
tenemos que multiplicar por 1.8 por lo
tanto x es tres veces 1.8 y cuánto es
eso bueno 3 por 18 54 así que x es igual
a 5.4 vamos a verificar 1.8 por 33 por 8
es 24 3 por 1 es tres más dos que ya
teníamos es 5 y tenemos una cifra
después del punto decimal así nos queda
5.4 hemos terminado
nos vemos en otro vídeo